yeah yeah yeah 2x not tan han 4 tee [music] yeah yeah yeah [music] yeah yeah yeah [music] th ah ah ah
[music]
tan
[music]  ]
rar
[Music]
How was it? What the hell did we see now? That's
why I'm participating in the world's best-selling game minecraft Smash Bros.
I didn't expect to come
That's why the person in charge of Nintendo comes and says Sakurai Come on,
can't you put Minecraft in a smash bra?
You might have misunderstood something,
but I know what kind of game Minecraft is. It
's impossible to put that game on a smasher while establishing a bargain, so I said clearly, I
'm going to get
closer.
I think it
's just crap
And if you want to put a block on every stage of the stage, you
have to
make some changes, what should the old lady do,
and so on. After all, it's a plan and an adjustment of the game balance.
It can be said that it is an unknown area in the state. It
is very difficult to put together well including the big tree and the short reach, but the
construction will be very different, but somehow it will be released.  I
'm about to get rid of it, so I've announced today and reported on the participating movie.
I think I've learned to some extent from the movie in favor, but there are many more.
I want to do this for the presentation after all. I think that
there are many elements that are completely different from the fighters so far, so I hope you can take a closer look and use it
.
The broadcast is here.
I had an opportunity just before and decided to explain it again.
Of course I also play Minecraft. I
don't do relay construction in craft mode, but
I enjoy survival and prosperity of the town in survival mode.
How to use Steve Palax for broadcasting at a later date
Please look forward to the broadcasting.
[Music]